de raíces japonesas y nacionalidad
peruana hija del polémico ex presidente
del perú alberto fujimori quien cumple
condena de 25 años de prisión por
violaciones a los derechos humanos pero
también madre esposa administradora de
empresas política ex primera dama ex
congresista y presidenta del partido
fuerza popular la fama de su padre le
jugó en contra en las dos últimas
elecciones pero esto no impidió que su
partido político se el protagonista en
este último gobierno en el que lideraron
el proceso de destitución de tres
presidentes en un plazo de cinco años
que conoce con forma y mucho menos se
rinde y hoy por tercera vez lucha para
convertirse en la primera presidenta del
país suramericano sin embargo en estas
elecciones carga con un peso que no
cargaba antes su paso por prisión
preventiva en dos ocasiones por presunta
responsabilidad en lavado de activos y
otros delitos relacionados con el
escándalo de corrupción de odebrecht
pero ella se resiste a perder insiste en
que el país permanezca bajo el régimen
de la democracia propone mejorar la
educación reactivar la economía
devolverle la seguridad a los ciudadanos
darle más importancia al medio ambiente
luchar por la igualdad para mujeres y
fortalecer el sistema de salud cuya
mayor responsabilidad actualmente es
vencer el kobe 19 de ganar quedarían en
libertad ella y su padre de perder es
probable que el fujimorismo nunca más
llegue al poder en esta nación y que el
país viva bajo una nueva ideología el
perú decide